so we've been talking over the last
several weeks about just like the total
havoc that's been happening on the david
pakman show youtube channel and we had
the really great news earlier this week
of reaching 700,000 YouTube subscribers
I think we're now closer to seven
hundred and four thousand maybe seven
hundred and five and to catch you up
there have sort of been three primary
issues that were facing on the YouTube
channel which is just one of our outlets
right we're on 200 radio and TV stations
we've got an audio podcast that has been
growing significantly it has grown 40
percent since my appearance on the Joe
Rogan program interestingly enough and
that's been really great we've got the
free speech TV broadcast of the show on
DirecTV and Dish Network and then we've
got YouTube which is a big piece of what
we do the three issues we've been
dealing with are D prioritization in
YouTube's algorithm in favor of
corporate media what I mean by that is
when you watch a video on YouTube
YouTube recommends additional videos to
you and as I've detailed extensively I
won't do it again today
don't worry YouTube has been
increasingly suggesting people watch
corporate YouTube channels like CNN
MSNBC the late-night shows produced with
you know tens or hundreds of millions of
dollars behind them etc rather than
independent content like ours we've lost
about three million views a month as a
result of that algorithmic change the
other issue has been demonetised
that should be earning money they don't
violate any of YouTube's monetization
rules as they are written although the
devil seems to be in the interpretation
of those rules we will produce a video
research it edit upload all of that
stuff and then a YouTube algorithm will
determine it's not gonna run any ads
sorry you don't get to make any money
off of this content you've spent all day
creating that's been issue number two an
issue number three which is the one I've
spoken the least about is people
reporting to me that they have been
subscribed for a long time in many cases
and then all of a sudden they notice
they're not seeing our videos on their
homepage anymore they specifically go to
our channel and all of a sudden they
realize they're not even subscribed we
have not talked that much about it I
have been telling YouTube for months
every time I have a call with our
YouTube rep I say or almost every time
we are continuing to get dozens of
emails from people who say I'm not
incompetent I know I was subscribed to
your channel I am now unsubscribed and
one of the unfortunate things is that we
just hit 700,000 subscribers who knows
where we would be were this
unsubscription problem not an issue and
I finally got a video from a viewer of
this happening and you will notice that
the viewer this is on youtubes mobile
app similar activity has been told to me
is taking place on desktop a viewer sent
me a video from mobile and you see him
click on to our channel and even though
he thought he was subscribed he wasn't
he clicks the subscribe button it seems
to work and as soon as he comes right
back to our channel he has again been
unsubscribed so this is only part one
like this is the issue of subscribe
isn't sticking and he immediately
noticed it the bigger issue might be
people who have been subscribed for a
long time they are subscribed to a bunch
of channel so they don't necessarily
immediately notice that they're not
seeing our videos and their subscription
feed they come back to our channel when
they think about it and they realize oh
I've been unsubscribed from the David
Pakman show
and this has a cumulative effect what I
mean by that is subscriber growth
creates subscriber growth if you have a
hundred people who are subscribed and
sharing your content now everyone who
sees those hundred people's social media
posts about our content are more likely
to become subscribers themselves they
are then likely to generate more
subscribers for us so the value of one
subscriber has a sort of economic
multiplier effect to use an economic
term if there are a thousand people
unsubscribed that means there are a
thousand fewer people sharing our
content from which we would derive even
more subscribers in the future so this
is depressing it's disappointing I can
do nothing about it I've told you too
about it probably 20 times if you have
other videos like the one we showed or
other information if you're noticing
it's happening in particular browsers if
you're noticing it's happening on mobile
and not desktop or vice versa any
information you have please get to me I
don't have any reason to think right now
that this is malicious
a lot of people report this I think it's
a glitch that YouTube simply hasn't
fixed because even though many people
tell them about it rarely do we have
examples like this on video now we have
one ok so let me know if you have any
more light to shed on this problem